démocratiser l'accès à la culture même
au temps du coc vide
un souhait pour la mairie de trappes qui
pour cela va développer plusieurs
projets comme le plan lecture pour tous
qui sera l'occasion pour nous de
développer l'activité de la librairie le
millefeuille de lui permettre de
s'épanouir au coeur des quartiers en
pied d'immeuble et de donner aux enfants
avant même le cp l'occasion de découvrir
le livre la ville de trappes a reçu pour
l'occasion le préfet de la région ile de
france après un passage à la librairie
le millefeuille les élus territoriaux se
sont rendus au cinéma le grenier à sel
puisque l'un des projets et d'associer
la programmation culturelle aux
habitants de trappes pour les jeunes les
jeunes gens par exemple d'aller à
travers la france découvrir dans les
festivals de culture quand on sera
évidemment sortie de la période de
pandémie de découvrir les différentes
diversité culturelle de notre pays et de
les importer ici à trappes
en fin de visite les élus du département
et de la région sont allés au
conservatoire de musique et de danse
en cette période où la culture est
malmené la région souhaite soutenir ce
genre de projets culturels
la variété des projets des talents nous
fait penser qu'on pourra essayer
d'accompagner la ville de trappes dans
ses différents projets avec un fil rouge
l'éducation artistique et culturelle et
c'est contractualiser avec elle pour
sécuriser des crédits des actions et se
projeter dans le futur
l'après midi s'est clôturé par une table
ronde avec les acteurs associatifs et
culturels
on les représentants territoriaux et l
écoute de nos projets moi ça fait trente
ans que je me bats ici bas de voir que
là on a une et coup d'état fort que ça
donne envie d'aller encore plus loin de
créer des nouvelles vedettes de de faire
que cette ville elle soit regarder aussi
ailleurs comme un lieu de culture avant
tout et ça c'est déterminant autre
projet le centre technique municipal
deviendra un tiers lieu nommé la
fabrique où se mêleront artistes et
artisans